je pense souvent à mon grand père c'est
mon fil conducteur mon grand père je me
souviens que quand j'étais petit il
tenait des livres de contes à la virgule
près pour être sûrs de nous distribuer à
chacun la même quantité dé trend à nous
tous ses enfants et ses petits-enfants
petit compter presque les fraises dans
nos assiettes pour être sûr qu'on en ait
chacun la même par la justice et
l'honnêteté
ce sont des valeurs fortes qui m'a
transmise sont importantes pour moi et
pourtant j'ai l'impression que ces
valeurs là les miennes sont en décalage
avec la façon dont le monde fonctionne
aujourd'hui et je vous donne un exemple
très simple qui parmi vous paye des
impôts
pas mal quand même
c'est bien mon grand père ne se
plaignait jamais de payer des impôts
ils trouvaient ça juste et honnête de
participer au collectif pour mille
choses utiles et moi je me suis rendu
compte récemment que dans nos impôts on
payait 500 euros par an à cause des
pesticides et ça ça me pose question
500 euros par an c'est ce que coûtent
les pesticides juste sur la santé dans
nos cotisations sociales nos impôts donc
c'est concrètement un peu de maladies
professionnelles pour les agriculteurs
c'est une intoxication lent dans notre
alimentation et qui va se traduire un
jour par des troubles de développement
chez les enfants de l'autisme des
maladies de parkinson des problèmes
d'infertilité
alors déjà je trouve qu'en matière de
transparence et d'honnêteté c'est quand
même un peu limite ses charges qu'on
paye pour réparer et sans vraiment nous
en rendre compte
et moi ce qui met vraiment plus en
colère c'est de savoir que ces
entreprises qui produisent ces presti
side et qui savent très bien quelles
sont leurs impacts sur la santé
eh bien elles peuvent avoir des
résultats économiques positifs monsanto
dont on parlait déjà tout à l'heure
eh bien ils peuvent afficher 2 milliards
de dollars 2 milliards de dollars de
bénéfices par an depuis cinq ans c'est
énorme ça quand même
non c'est pas énorme allez c'est énorme
mais moi je trouve ça super injuste et
ça ça s'appelle une défaillance du
marché c'est à dire qu'on a un système
qui cautionnent quelque chose qui est
totalement inadmissible mais c'est
parfaitement légal c'est comme ça alors
des exemples comme ça elle a beaucoup et
il ya deux façons de réagir
la première façon de réagir quand on a
le sang chaud eh ben on envie de tout
casser parce qu'on est quand même dans
un système pourri 1 ces multinationales
qui s'en mettre plein les poches
1 quand même et ses patrons là il y en a
dans la fana des patrons ouais hein
il se cache un le capitalisme c'est le
système à abattre parce que l'argent sa
cour en tout voilà vous voyez le genre
sinon ben quand on est un petit peu
moins par un petit peu plus calme et on
comprend le système comme il est parce
que quand même il ya des gens qui
s'occupent de ça c'est pas trop notre
responsabilité est là et par rentrer
dans le moule piano milieu là et on fait
ce qu'on peut
et rentrer dans le moule et bien c'est
ce que je fais moi tous les jours dans
mon métier
j'accompagne des collectivités et des
entreprises à intégrer le développement
durable dans leurs activités
et puisqu'on parlait des pesticides et
bunge explique par exemple que
l'agriculture biologique c'est beaucoup
mieux pour la santé que ça crée beaucoup
plus d'emplois
je crée des argumentaires béton je
calcule je fais des je fais ça pour que
ça rentre dans le moule et ben en fait
j'adore mon métier
en fait j'adore ce que je fais parce que
je trouve ça super utile et moi je
change le monde
ouais
enfin je croyais parce que quand je fais
un pas de côté
je me rends compte qu'il ya quand même
un problème moi j'ai l'impression de
jouer à tetris toute la journée j'ai un
modèle économique comme ça qui est un
peu obligatoire et étriquée tous les
trucs dont je parle à tous ces bénéfices
seront jamais dans les comptes et autour
de ça j'ai des solutions qui sont les
emplois de demain qui sont les sondés
s'ils sont les solutions d'avenir qui
sont des évidences et ça rentre pas dans
le cadre
et pendant que moi je joue au tetris
pendant que je jette tout mon coeur
toute ma passion mais qu'est ce qui se
passe en vrai pendant que je fais ça eh
ben la banquise elle continue de fondre
la biodiversité elle s'érode les
abeilles disparaissent les centres
commerciaux pouces là où on avait des
terres agricoles mais moi le mur qu'on a
en face de nous ça me terrifie le rythme
on va
c'est flippant
alors heureusement j'ai rencontré le
professeur jacques richard et en
étudiant les travaux déjà j'ai compris
qu'au lieu d'aller abattre le
capitalisme ou de rentrer dans le moule
on pouvait tout simplement imaginer de
le rendre plus intelligent de
l'intérieur de le hac est en quelque
sorte je vous explique son idée géniale
mais qu'est ce que c'est le capitalisme
le capitalisme c'est un truc qui est
programmé pour faire une seule chose
préserver le capital financier
le capitalisme il ne pense qu'à ça il ne
sait faire que ça
est il logique que sur ça et il le fait
très bien mais est ce que vous vous êtes
demandé un jour ce que c'est le capital
eh bien le capital c'est ce qui est
capital c'est ce qui est fondamental
c'est ce qui est très important pour
nous l'espèce humaine est ce que
capitale en 2017
et bien c'est par exemple les ressources
du sol du sous sol etc la terre c'est ce
qui nous permettent de nous nourrir de
nous loger de nous déplacer de nous
vêtir de vivre quand ce qui est capital
c'est la santé et le bien-être le nôtre
et ceux de nos enfants c'est aussi la
beauté de nos paysages
c'est la diversité de notre gastronomie
tout ce qui fait notre culture
je vous assure c'est infiniment
compliqué de le faire rentrer dans les
comptes
et pourtant quand on le perd on sait ce
que ça nous coûte alors pour faire son
job de préservation du capital le
capitalisme a un cerveau qui s'appelle
la comptabilité
alors là moi quand j'ai compris ça je me
suis dit que les travaux que jacques
richard j'allais peut-être pas aller
très loin
parce que s'il ya bien une discipline
qui est très enfin pas trop
enfin vous voyez quoi c'est la compta
coin
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais on parle jamais de
comptabilité au cinéma c'est louche ça
quand même
vous imaginez un film qui s'appellerait
star wars la revanche des comptes à ça
le fait pas j'ai mieux encore 50 nuance
de comptabilité
ça rentre pas on comprend tout de suite
l'intérêt de la version originale et
bien c'est une grave erreur
j'ai compris que même les experts
comptables pouvait être aventureux
sulfureux inventif et oui on peut tout à
fait moderniser le cerveau du
capitalisme et pour ça il suffit de le
doter d'une nouvelle paire de lunettes
aujourd'hui il faut s'imaginer que le
capitalisme et la comptabilité
fonctionne comme un cyclope
c'est à dire qu'il ne voit que les
masses d'argent les flux les entrées les
chiffres d'affaires les machines les
bâtiments et ça c'est ok l'argent c'est
pas mal ça marche très bien
c'est très utile ça en jette pas une
nouvelle paire de lunettes c'est ce qui
va permettre capitalisme de voir aussi
le capital naturel et le capital humain
et cette comptabilité nouvelle et
intégrale et intégré ça existe vraiment
ça s'appelle la comptabilité en triple
capital financier naturel humain vous le
répéter que moi là pour eux comptabilité
en triple capitale je vous écoute
bah c'est génial donc ça existe vraiment
et ce qui est extraordinaire avec cette
paire de lunettes c'est qu'on voit ces
trois capitaux de manière hyper
distingue c'est à dire que si dans mon
activité économique
je dégrade par exemple je détruis une
espèce vivante capital naturel où je
détruis du bien-être ou la santé de mes
consommateurs capital humain et ben ça
va se voir dans les comptes et ça ça
change tout l'invisible devient visible
et pour vous démontrer la puissance de
ce truc je vous raconte comment cette
année on l'a mis en oeuvre dans des
fermes agro écologiques alors les fermes
agro écologiques qu'on soit clair c'est
pas c'est pas une lubie d'écolo
altermondialiste en sandales qui mangent
du tofu et des graines germées
du matin au soir c'est pas du tout ça
les fermes agro écologiques
ce sont celles qui innovent tous les
jours avec la nature et pas contre elle
c'est d'une technicité incroyable il n'y
a pas un algorithme de google au monde
un jour qui fera le job d'un agriculteur
qui résonne agro écologie est un
agriculteur comme ça j'en ai rencontré
plusieurs mais un en particulier que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle stéphane
sabots stéphanie les installer il est
installé dans l'allier en auvergne est
il en train de convertir la ferme
familiale en polyculture élevage et en
agriculture biologique
c'est l'un des pionniers cette année qui
a osé utiliser explorer la comptabilité
en triple capital dans sa ferme
quand on regarde ce qui se passe chez
lui avec cette méthode on se rend compte
de quoi on se rend compte déjà que
stephane dans les deux dernières années
il a planté plus d'un kilomètre de
l'être sur son exploitation élire les
deux prochaines années y plantera 4000
arbres
voyez ce que ça représente 4000 arbres
ça fait quand même une petite forêt sain
et bien quand il fait ça stéphane il
décide de réduire sa surface productive
et donc sont revenus à court terme pour
préserver à long terme son capital
naturel qui est aussi le nôtre
et quand il fait ça il n'est pas payé eh
bien avec la comptabilité en triple
capitale
on compte ce temps et ça change tout on
se rend compte aussi par ces pratiques
que stéphane il génère pour nous pour la
société des services nombreux tels que
la qualité sanitaire de ces produits la
qualité de l'eau tels que des réserves
de gibier pour les chasseurs ou du
maintien de l'emploi agricole dans son
territoire
quand on met bout à bout tous ses
bénéfices pour nous ça représente pour
stéphane jusqu'à 3000 euros par hectare
et par an et ça c'est énorme pour lui et
ça change tout l'invisible devient
visible
le jour où stéphane va décider de vendre
sa ferme ce qui peut arriver
et bien la valeur de sa ferme elle sera
plus importante que celle de son voisin
qui dans le même temps pourrait avoir
dégradé son sol sa faune et sa flore il
faut s'imaginer qu'aujourd'hui un sol
naturellement productif va avoir la même
valeur qu'un sol dégradé dépendant des
engrais trouvez ça normal vous eh ben
non moi ça me choque et avec cette
méthode là on va pouvoir rendre ça
beaucoup plus juste alors ça imaginez un
peu pour ces femmes c'est génial à 3000
euros par hectare et par an mais si on
appliquait ca sur l'ensemble de
l'agriculture mais c'est la révolution
c'est la dynamique de la transition et
agricoles parce que imagine un peu tous
les agriculteurs ils vont voir l'intérêt
économique de préserver leurs trois
capitaux financiers naturel et humain
ça permettra un changement d'échelle
radical par rapport à cette transition
dont on a besoin et ça c'est de la
dynamite pour les agriculteurs mais ça
marche partout et c'est de la dynamite
aussi pour nous les consommateurs
imaginez ces entreprises qui parfois
peuvent avoir des pratiques un peu
douteuse en matière d'environnement ou
en matière de santé santé de leurs
collaborateurs santé de leur client
avec cette méthode qu'est ce qui va se
passer on va voir leurs résultats
économiques se dégradent et puisqu'on va
internaliser ses coûts cachés
vous savez les 500 euros que vous payez
tous dans vos impôts l'un donc leur
performance va se dégrader
elles ne seront plus compétitive et
leurs produits vont devenir super cher
et nous quand on fera nos courses
mais ce qui va se passer c'est que les
produits qui seront au juste prix ce
seront les produits responsables et ça
ça change tout les produits recyclés les
énergies renouvelables les vêtements
éthiques
l'alimentation de qualité c'est énorme
ça quand même
donc ça c'est génial pour nous
consommateurs qui sommes déjà soigneux
quand nous faisons nos courses
mais c'est surtout un changement
d'échelle radical pour toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
poser les mêmes questions que nous et
qui
achète uniquement par rapport aux
critères de prix s'il ya une seule chose
à retenir de ce que je vous dis c'est
que la comptabilité c'est le réacteur
nucléaire de notre système de valeurs
la comptabilité c'est le feu sous la
glace on n'a pas envie de s'en occuper
mais c'est un pouvoir de transformation
comme ça sur notre société
il n'y a pas un accélérateur plus
puissant que la comptabilité en triple
capitale pour relever les défis
écologiques et sociaux qui sont les
nôtres
alors comment agir vous avez envie
d'agir
nous avons envie de faire un truc là
heskey dans la salle des chefs
d'entreprise des banquiers des
comptables je vous assure vous allez
sortir vivants bon super vous êtes dans
la sphère d'influencé vous pouvez sortir
du moule et non seulement vous pouvez
mais en plus vous avez un intérêt à le
faire
vous avez là la méthode qui va vous
permettre de montrer noir sur blanc dans
les comptes
tout ce que vous faites déjà bien il ya
des gens qui sont pas chefs
d'entreprises qui sont pas banquier dans
la salle eh ben vous pouvez en parler
autour de vous vous pouvez partager
cette idée
et quand vous consommez surtout en
attendant que ça se mette en place
continue à vous poser des questions
avec notre ticket de caisse à chaque
acte d'achat tous les jours on a un
pouvoir d'influencé majeure sur le
fonctionnement des entreprises
alors si dans les prochains jours vous
croisez un chef d'entreprise ou un
journaliste qui vient vous parler de la
performance d'une entreprise de ces gros
résultats et de ses gros capitaux et
bien posé lui cette question mais de
quelle capitale me parlez vous et si en
face de vous vous avez un cyclope
et bien offrez lui une bonne paire de
lunettes
[Applaudissements]